défaut de soins défaut d'alimentation
chez les tout-petits harcèlement d'une
jeune fille dans les douches
voici quelques-uns des signalements
faits au procureur par l'administrateur
provisoire chargé du foyer de gâchettes
depuis un an les éléments révélés par
deux élus de la commission santé de la
ctm feliz catherine et louise tél dans
leur courrier au procureur et au
président marie jeanne il dénonce une
maltraitance avérée chronique des
enfants de l'institution et plus
généralement une psychose de la peur au
sein du personnel qui impacterait le
bien-être des enfants
aujourd'hui contrainte de s'exprimer la
ctm dit partager les mêmes inquiétudes
qui l'ont amené à nommer
l'administrateur provisoire en 2010 est
depuis de longues années il y à des
dysfonctionnements à gâchette et lorsque
l'administrateur provisoire nous a fait
remonter des cas de maltraitance qui
vont monter parfois 2013 à 2014 2015 est
certain aussi maintenant nous lui avons
demandé immédiatement sans délai de
signaler ces situations au procureur ce
qui a été fait parce que nous
considérons qu'il ne faut pas avoir de
tolérance vis-à-vis d'actes qui est
violent l'intégrité de nos enfants qui
dit finalement au procureur dit future
enquête de gendarmerie
et s'il faut encore déterminer
précisément les responsabilités
le fonctionnement même de l'association
la sainte famille est clairement pointée
du doigt
on peut enlever l'agrément et lorsqu'on
regarde la stabilité de la direction de
l'association qui est en charge des
structures de gâchette on peut
s'interroger ce cela que ce qu'il a à
faire il peut y avoir aussi d'autres
mesures
mais ce sont des mesures qui vont
permettre de protéger des enfants de ce
qu'est notre rôle fondamental
aujourd'hui nous n'avons pu joindre le
président de la sainte famille la ctm
préconise déjà le déplacement de
certains enfants vers d'autres
institutions
fin octobre l'administrateur provisoire
en fin de mandat rendra ses
préconisations à la ctm mais quoi qu'il
arrive le foyer de gâchettes restera
sous administration de la justice